una sacudida política en la única
democracia parlamentaria de asia central
el lunes los manifestantes se tomaron a
la fuerza a la casa blanca de kirguistán
donde están la presidencia y el
parlamento
horas después la comisión electoral
central anuló las elecciones
parlamentarias del domingo al considerar
que hubo fraude por parte del
oficialismo denunció que se repetirán
los comicios antes del día de las
elecciones hubo numerosas quejas sobre
sobornos y el apoyo de entidades
públicas
es nuestra tierna perezosa esto llevó a
la renuncia del primer ministro cuba tec
vóronov y de más de seis autoridades
locales ahora la oposición que había
perdido las elecciones tiene la mayoría
del poder en un proceso con tropiezos
shadix a paro fundó uno de los partidos
opositores y estaba en la cárcel pagando
una pena de 11 años por tomar como rehén
a un funcionario del gobierno en 2013
pero la oposición decía que todo era una
estrategia del gobierno para
deslegitimar a su contendor un antiguo
funcionario
y en las manifestaciones del martes
entraron a la cárcel donde estabas a
paros y lo liberar después el parlamento
lo nombró como el primer ministro según
informan medios locales aunque las
protestas también son contra el
presidente sobre un buy-in bekoff el
mandatario sigue en el poder e hizo un
llamado a sus fuerzas para que no usen
la violencia mientras que al país le
pidió serenidad llamó a todas las partes
a poner el destino del país por encima
de cualquier ambición política y vuelvan
a obedecer la ley
las protestas han dejado un joven de 19
años muerto casi 700 heridos y un país
con sus instituciones en disputa